you've covered these you've covered
these under quadratic theory these were
called at least this specific kind was
called a quadratic identity okay so i'm
just going to rehearse the way it goes
through because i don't know how many of
you actually remember anything from back
then but maybe you sort of rush through
it because you're focusing on the roots
and coefficients or something or who
knows
so how does this work okay
we're going to do this in much the same
way we're doing things already which is
that when you've got two things you know
that they're equal to each other right
and importantly you've got like say you
know x squared terms right
they never mix with x terms
i mean you can factorize them but
they're still two different things right
so all of the x squared terms over here
must be equivalent to all the x squared
terms over here whatever they are okay
so we can do some comparisons of
coefficients here on both sides and then
we'll move on and we'll do an example
with higher degrees so you can see it's
basically the same idea
so the way this would work is
um i'm just trying to think yeah i'm
gonna take the right hand side
okay
and i have to expand it out there's no
kind of shortcut way for that right so
i've got a outside of
that
plus expand sorry
expand this
and you got that flying over on the end
okay
expand this out properly so i've got
um
okay now because where i'm going where
i'm headed towards is comparison of
coefficients right i want to put this
into a form that makes the comparison
easiest okay so i've got my x squared my
x and my constant on the left hand side
so i'll do the same on the right hand
side right gather all the x squared
terms of which there is only
one right namely ax squared so i don't
need to touch that
but i do have a pair of x terms right
i've got this 4ax
you may even want to get out some colors
just so you don't
confuse these right and i've got that bx
flying on the end so
to make the coefficient stand out i'll
stick them in brackets okay
and then lastly
i've got this 4a 2b and c and all of
those together comprise this constant
term okay
okay so again i put it back it's not
because i have to but because it um
looks elegant like brendan does right
now okay so
now i can say by comparison of
coefficients
because it's just the one x squared term
right i can straight away say a is going
to be equal to three no problems okay
likewise i can say four a plus b is
equal to minus four
but because i already know what 8 is
right i can say that's 12
so this is minus 16 by the looks of it
yep that all checks out okay and then
lastly
this minus seven is equal to all those
together right
so let's substitute in i've got four
times three which is twelve
two times minus sixteen which is minus
thirty-two
this is minus twenty so i'll add twenty
to both sides and that'll give me
thirteen okay
now in this case the question was find a
b and c so i actually am done at this
point okay
however occasionally they'll just
re-word the question just a little bit
and they'll say
write 3x squared minus 4x minus 7 in the
form
this right so in that case all that's
left to do is to take my a my b and my c
and rewrite it like so
3x squared minus 4x minus seven
is equal to for all values of x
this
now what is this called
this first quadrant that we started with
right
it's a quadratic
and this is the the way they use the
language
in x right so x is the thing that's
being squared and x is there's one there
and so on so what i've got here on the
right hand side and down here right
this is a quadratic
in x plus two
okay so x plus two is kind of like my
variable right but sometimes they'll ask
you for a quadratic in this or that or
the other and this is what they actually
mean it's all in terms of x plus twos
okay
right now just to move on to the next
one i'm not going to finish it off but
just show you how
the same principle works okay
5a 5b says
that 2x cubed minus 8x squared plus 3x
minus 4 is equivalent to
this okay
so
it's going to work in exactly the same
way i'm going to have to expand out this
right hand side
and i'll just give you a um a tip which
goes back to sword review seven and is a
topic which will revisit your tool
called binomial but just to make things
a little quicker for you
when you're expanding out things that
are cubed okay
the way that
if you take any kind of polynomial two
terms and you cube it okay
the coefficients of all the terms are
going to come from the third row of
pascal's triangle do you remember that
one
and when i say third i'm counting this
as the zeroth
row because it's kind of a loner it
doesn't it's not really useful for any
math really so this is the third row so
that one three three one okay those are
going to be my coefficients so this is
going to be one lot of a cubed
three lots of a squared b
three lots of a b squared and
one lot of b cubed okay and if i raise
it to the power four i just take the
coefficients from
the next line okay now why is that
well if you can be patient enough to
wait 12 months i will explain but for
now you can just use this just save you
a little bit of time rather than
actually doing this and then multiplying
it and expanding the whole thing out
you're going to land on let's do it
together
outside of
one lot of that
three lots of this
three lots of this and
one lot of them okay the signs alternate
by the way because of that minus one
yeah just be careful um plus
by the way can you see again one two one
just like that's good triangle
um plus this
plus this and you're going to do the
same thing that we did here rearrange
everything so the coefficients are nice
and
they line up properly and then solve it
that's all